hello and welcome to learning about it
with me Lulu today we're going to be
learning about skewers a skewer is like
a pin except in the skewer the more
valuable pieces pinned to the less
valuable piece so the piece can't move
without risk of losing material so here
it's black to play how can we provoke
white and deciding of a powerful skewer
Knight g4 check so now the King can't
move to e4
because mate comes in a few moves
checkmate
so he has to play King d3 putting his
King on the same diagonal as Queen so
now we can skewer these pieces here with
[ __ ] of f5 check the King has to move
and now we win the Queen
so here it's white to play can you find
a good skewer in this position it's
bishop f1 securing the Queen and the
rook so the Queen moves and now we get
to trade the bishop for the rook alright
so today we learn about skewers a skewer
is a little bit like a pin just
backwards anyways thanks for learning
about it with me Lulu and make sure to
LIKE and subscribe